[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by sonos
boy do i love sonos i have told you
about this a million times don't change
the channel i'm trying to tell you
something here
well whatever they do the fast forwards
or whatever i have sonos for 18 years
they weren't a sponsor and i had spent
money on sonos for many many years and
finally they became a sponsor and it
makes me happy because it's a product
that i love talking about it's a product
that works i have sonos devices all over
my house they're sleek
slim
sexy
they fit anywhere they don't bulk up the
room with big speakers and and you know
receivers and all these things
it just goes off like in my room i have
eight different speakers in eight
different rooms i could play a
different song in each room i have party
mode i have bedroom mode for sleep uh
they're just a wonderful thing and now
we have the sonos rome ryan tell us
about the sonos rome sonos rome is the
ultra portable smart speaker that allows
you to bring the sonos experience
everywhere you go rome weighs less than
a pound and its premium durable design
makes it perfect for the home and for on
the go when you're home rome connects to
your wi-fi network and the rest of your
sonos system and then automatically
pairs with your phone on bluetooth when
you're on the go for a seamless
experience using automatic true play
tuning roam smartly adapts to your
surroundings and whatever you're
listening to and creates sound that's
astonishingly detailed and perfectly
balanced control rome using the app
apple airplay 2 or your voice with
amazon alexa or google assistant with
sonos you could start with one speaker
and expand your system over time like i
have all sonos speakers connect over
wi-fi so you can group speakers in
different rooms and play music
throughout your home and you are going
to enjoy this it's perfect time for the
holidays folks it's time to get some
sonos in your house you will not
be
disappointed
sonos check it out guys you're listening
to inside of you with michael rosenbaum
very assertive today
i hope you're having a wonderful day
ryan how's your day i'm doing all right
i'd like to hear that yes yes yes we're
doing yes we're doing it we're doing it
all right okay uh thanks for listening
thanks for tuning in thanks for uh
spending an hour with me
every week
if you're here for jason alexander only
i appreciate that but hopefully you'll
stick around if you like
my voice
or you like my interviewing style i hope
you do uh it was a real treat
interviewing jason alexander before we
get that let me just say a few things
my band will be playing november 20th
virtually you can watch it and uh
there's prizes and zooms go to
sunspin.com the band is called sunspin
you go to sunspin.com and you can also
go to stage it type in sunspin and get
your tickets please support the band
sunspin sunspin.com also has merch
and the inside of you online store has
tons of really great stuff
lex luthor stuff smallville stuff inside
of you stuff tumblers
just a bunch of great stuff you can get
there to support the podcast and lovable
patrons i love you thank you for
supporting the podcast if you want to
join patreon
they give to the podcast a little more
they keep the podcast afloat they help
me pay for extra stuff so i can give you
a good quality show uh just go to
patreon.com
inside of you p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com
slash inside of you join the family
there's uh there's lots of tiers and
things you can get perks and it's become
a big family so i don't need to talk too
much about that i could probably talk
about it for an hour
um lastly i will just say that uh my
charity that i work with i'm on the
board for echoes of hope um
for the next month or two if you want to
donate or help out echoes of hope
we're hosting a holiday event for
under-resourced children teens and young
adults roughly 300 students will be
supported this december and if they want
to purchase a gift if you guys want to
purchase a gift or two you can visit our
wish list on amazon by going to at our
echoes of hope on social media
these are students who a lot of times do
not have family so they oftentimes spend
the holidays alone
and it can be a very difficult time for
them
um so we host the holiday party to make
the holiday season special for them
visit our website too
echoesofhope.org and there's a bunch of
different options for giving on the
donate page so i will say that and
lastly
this is a really cool product they sent
me a bunch of stuff and they're not a
sponsor they don't get paid for this but
they sent me a bunch of it's called mead
have you heard of mead me like the the
thing that knights drink yes pretty much
i mean that's what it is originally
founded in 2017 by travis zigler and
taylor tolle who are making mead in a
closet and doing leather work on a
kitchen table weird
weird it's called has made quite an
impact on portland
in the past year weird settled into its
current location with the partnership of
doug winsgate at uh in 2019 and weird
leatherworks and meadery has brought a
new medieval fantasy themed business
specializing in the production of
handmade leather goods such as armor
belts and accessories for film as well
as producing their own
mead yes weird not only sells and serves
its own brand of meat but makes it right
on site it's similar to wine meat is
brewed using honey as a sugar source
instead of grapes that's the oldest
alcoholic beverage in the world
uh you just need to really try this
stuff it is wonderful i really really
loved it i was surprised that i loved it
so much it's just tasty weird is a nerdy
medieval fantasy pop culture loving
business that is heavily focused around
the community and spell w-y-r-d
uh and recently played host to the rose
city comic-con launch party so for more
information and helping these guys out
it's a small company uh or ordering or
visiting the meadery
go to weird leatherandmede.com it's
w-y-r-d-l-e-a-t-h-e-r-a-n-d-m-e-a-d.com
weird spell w-y-r-d leather
and become a warrior of weird
uh congratulations guys i hope you guys
do well and i hope people uh purchase
some stuff by the way if you want to
listen to the podcast or if you want to
continue listening please subscribe
please write a review tell your friends
and also ryan tell us the handles that
they could follow the podcast the follow
inside of you pod on twitter and at
inside of your podcast on instagram and
facebook
that is correct so thank you for
listening thank you for enjoying the
show if you do enjoy it and continue to
write me and tell me what you think
um
i think that's about it uh make sure you
uh donate if you can to echoes of hope
and check out weird wyrd they're meadery
i love those guys and i just want to
give them a little props is there
anything wrong with that that was really
cool yeah why not let's get inside of
one of my favorite people uh jason
alexander has been around for a long
time he's not old and he looks really
good but uh
i love talking to him and uh i was
excited i felt like a kid in a candy
store and uh he had some admiration for
me mutual we had mutual admiration and
uh it was a real treat so uh i think
you're really gonna enjoy this one uh we
get a little deep let's get inside of
jason alexander
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience hey you look really good
stop it finish your thoughts no that was
the that was the thought you you you
look good you look healthy you look uh
refreshed you look like you uh you're
sleeping well none of the above but
bless you do you not do you not sleep
well
uh i'm all you know that's the thing
that comes with age seriously that i
find um
so i'm about to turn 62.
it's not old by the way i find for the
last three years
you know it's like if you get three
hours and then you're kind of up and
then it's a little hard to get back down
you get another two to three so like six
hours is a big night for me i used to be
an eight hour guy nine hours ago but
and i used to remember my grandparents
would you know they never slept
and i'd go grandma go to sleep and she's
just i think it's one of those things it
just
it's a hormonal change like you just
don't need it is it do you not need as
much sleep when you're when you get i
think he needed just as much but i think
if you go back to the caveman days
you know who who was really vulnerable
kids little kids and old people and i
think they were wired to wake up every
now and then in case there was a lion in
the cave or something it was just
self-preservation we haven't weaned out
of it yet do you go to bed stressed do
you have anything to stress about it
these days uh you know uh depends on the
day do you know anyone who is like
i'm stress-free right now the world is
good i feel like i'm the only one i feel
like i'm the only one that stresses
about everything no
i think everybody is is
stressed out of their minds at this
point i don't i don't know how you can
i mean listen i i don't stress about
things that a lot of people stress about
i'm not worried about how am i gonna pay
the rent or put food on the table thank
god but but i think everybody is
stressed out if you're engaged with the
world you're you're concerned
uh and some of those concerns can be
existential at some times and uh yeah i
think i think people stress yeah do you
remember meeting me
tell me where it was that'll help i mean
here's why i feel i know you and you
know i'm not gonna i won't do the suck
up for the whole thing but
i was a major small girl geek major and
when you came on i went
they got it right holy crap they got it
right it was so
it was such a
smart casting on their part but really
smart writing and playing on your part
it was such an interesting
complex character and on kind of
unknowable as to what the real agenda
was going to be
and so smart on your part for a number
of reasons one it was just good work but
we all know when you're doing a tv
series you don't know what these guys
are going to do next you know make it
through your bone in episode 8 where you
go
if i know that i would have come at this
a whole different way so you you had so
much
leeway you know
it was such a smart okay
i can go this way i can go this way what
do you got where are we going how are we
going and i just remember i used to say
to my wife this guy is good he's good do
you know how good that makes me feel i
mean coming from you that i mean look
you're a legend and my my brother is
more excited even about this than i am
about that i'm talking to you today
but we met
but that means the world to me it really
does and i know i it just does and in
fact i remember it was at norby walters
oh we played poker right we played poker
and you just you know i was like oh my
god jason alexander's here jason
alexander you're like and you said
something like that you said something
like i love your work on the show or
something and it just was like
what it was it's amazing when you're uh
the guys you look up to or women you
look up to that they they say something
like that it's just
have you had that in your life where
somebody
i i have i mean i've had it often and
it's always i remember um
i had worked for neil simon
you know back in the 80s when i was
mostly doing theater in new york
and i had a lovely
time with but we never got close but
somehow i was invited during the
seinfeld years to his home
for to celebrate a birthday office and i
was the only person there i'd never
heard of you know so
and johnny carson was there
and i
so wanted
to talk to him and just say thank you
for all that all those wonderful years
but i was very intimidated he's not
going to know who i am and you know he
gets bothered all the time and i sort of
psyched myself out and the third time i
passed him he got up and said i just
want to say uh i love your work on the
show and i was like oh my god oh my god
oh my god and now i had to like make up
the excuses for why i had walked by him
two times without saying anything i was
so intimidated i didn't want to bother
you
but yeah i um
i'll tell you the one that killed me
killed me
um i had never met dick van dyke
up to the point of this story but i
i did a tv movie by birdie in the role
that he created
and it went on the air and it was fun it
was fine i was proud of it it was fun
and the following day i don't know how
he got my address i got flowers and a
bottle of champagne
dear jason now i know how to play the
role thank you you were great big van
dyke and i went oh come on come on
that's it's that's stupid
do you save things like that
yes i save all this [ __ ] i saved if
somebody wrote a letter so i took a
picture with someone that's on the wall
yeah you bet cause i've always felt like
my career could be over tomorrow that's
it every time i'm working tomorrow and
at least i'll have you know being a fan
i'll have all this in my house like a
museum and i could say to somebody one
day i met that person i did this
absolutely you you what's what's the one
thing you have at your house
that you keep
um i have a bunch of stuff
the stuff that i really kind of put out
that i don't have in a book somewhere
are
are things like
um
i worked for stephen sondheim that was
my broadway debut
first day on the job he said everybody
please call me steve but you know i've
worked with him many times and i guess
we have i've never hung out with him but
we have a lovely rapport but i'm always
so aware that i'm working with
a very extraordinary human being and
i've never quite been
comfortable and relaxed around and my
fault not his you know it's just what i
carry right
and
several years about 15 years ago he was
celebrating his 75th birthday and he was
interviewed in the new york times and he
made a comment about i think my time may
have passed i don't know if i'm relevant
anymore i don't know that i have
anything else to offer
and i wrote him a letter i don't know
what possessed me to do this i wrote him
a pretty long letter that said stephen i
have a 10 year old son
that can sing one third of your canon
and the only reason he doesn't sing the
rest of it is he doesn't quite
understand what it's about he will
i said and he is not an unusual kid he
is you you are continuing to touch
people
around the world
everyone that i know who loves the
theater waits in anticipation of
anything you are willing to share with
us next be it a revival a new piece or
what
and i finished it by quoting him i said
there was a great man at the theater
once wrote
anything you do let it come from you
then it will be new give us more to see
give us more to see and i sent that off
he sent me back a card you know
where he said sometimes the right thing
comes at the right time your words came
at exactly the right time thank you i am
reinvigorated
i i believe you please give my best to
your son and you know it was just it was
a go and
i had never had that kind of heart cell
exchange with steve
and the fact that he that it came back
in that way and that it meant something
to him i that card is framed and sitting
you know about a mantle so it's it's
things like that it's it's it's usually
not from people
um who i don't know and i'm surprised
that i have
kind of said something nice it's from
people that i know and i've always kind
of been like
you know man i don't want to bother
though i don't want to i don't know
we're not friends exactly we're not
friends what are we you know let's just
keep it the way it is yeah so it's it's
when people like that kind of
go hey you know you have value to me i
go oh okay i love that
inside of you is brought to you by
sonos
boy do i love sonos i have told you
about this a million times don't change
the channel i'm trying to tell you
something here
well whatever they do the fast forwards
or whatever i have sonos for 18 years
they weren't a sponsor and i had spent
money on sonos for many many years and
finally they became a sponsor and it
makes me happy because it's a product
that i love talking about it's a product
that works i have sonos devices all over
my house they're sleek
slim
sexy
they fit anywhere they don't bulk up the
room with big speakers and and you know
receivers and all these things
it just goes off like in my room i have
eight different speakers in eight
different rooms i could play a different
song in each room i have party mode i
have bedroom mode for sleep uh
they're just a wonderful thing and now
we have the sonos roam ryan tell us
about the sonos roam sonos roam is the
ultra portable smart speaker that allows
you to bring the sonos experience
everywhere you go rome weighs less than
a pound and its premium durable design
makes it perfect for the home and for on
the go when you're home rome connects to
your wi-fi network and the rest of your
sonos system and then automatically
pairs with your phone on bluetooth when
you're on the go for a seamless
experience using automatic true play
tuning roam smartly adapts to your
surroundings and whatever you're
listening to and creates sound that's
astonishingly detailed and perfectly
balanced control rome using the app
apple airplay 2 or your voice with
amazon alexa or google assistant with
sonos you could start with one speaker
and expand your system over time like i
have all sonos speakers connect over
wi-fi so you can group speakers in
different rooms and play music
throughout your home and you are going
to enjoy this it's perfect time for the
holidays folks it's time to get some
sonos in your house you will not
be
disappointed sonos check it out guys
inside of you is brought to you by
better help what would we do without
better help ryan
are you still doing the better help
still doing the better help and is it
helping it is helping i love it i love
it i think you know we're in such a
climate and i think the climate's always
been there there's always been stressful
times for people there's always it's not
like life gets any easier it's just like
how do we make life easier
and that's better help better help the
folks at better health can really help
you whether you're struggling with grief
relationships or stress or you're having
trouble sleeping or meeting goals online
therapy might be for you it's for me
it's for ryan it's for millions and
millions of people around the world it
helps you live a better life better help
is secure online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with licensed professional therapists
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own accredited
therapist you can start communicating
under 48 hours
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist how easy is that you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available i'll tell you
you know therapists in los angeles can
cost hundreds and hundreds of dollars
and better help is just a great option
visit betterhelp.com
inside and join the over 2 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional in fact so many
people have been using better help that
they're recruiting additional therapists
in all 50 states
um
i just love better help i they've been a
sponsor for a long time and they're
helping a lot of people and i want to
thank betterhelp
inside you is sponsored by betterhelp
and our listeners get 10 off their first
month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com
inside that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
inside try better help many of my
friends have text me and said does this
really work
and they seem to have figured out that
it does
so check out betterhelp and get that
discount betterhelp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by chili sleep you know science tells us
that the best way to achieve and
maintain consistent deep sleep is by
lowering core body temperature
temperature controlled sleep restores
testosterone levels repairs muscle after
a hard day's work and improves cognitive
function so you're always starting your
day feeling sharp and alert chili sleep
makes customizable climate-controlled
sleep solutions that help you improve
your entire well-being chili sleep makes
the ooler and cube sleep systems hydro
powered temperature controlled mattress
toppers that fit over your existing
mattress to provide your ideal sleep
temperature these luxury mattress pads
keep your bed at the perfect temperature
for deep sleep whether you sleep hot or
cold these sleep systems are designed to
help you fall asleep stay asleep and
give you the confidence and energy to
power through your day imagine waking up
and not feeling tired chilly sleep can
help make that happen for an extra layer
of comfort they also make the chili
blanket the only weighted blanket that
can also be paired with a control unit
for the ultimate sweat-free sleep i have
sleep problems it's hard for me to sleep
i have pains and i love the perfect
temperature i love it to be nice and
cool in your bed like they said uh you
know your core body temperature it
lowers the core body temperature during
deep sleep and it's very important and
uh it's called science folks it's called
science hello head over to
chilisleep.com
iou to learn more and check out a
special offer available exclusively for
inside of you listeners and only for a
limited time that's chile
c-h-i-l-i sleep dot com slash iou to
take advantage of our exclusive discount
and wake up refreshed every day
i mean
you're very humble
but you you've done everything i mean
you really have i mean you actor
comedian film and stage director
magician dancer you've done broadway
you've won a tony one
at this point in your life
it's like
do you really need to do anything and
you keep doing things like the show
marvelous mrs maisel was one of the best
shows around you appeared on that and
you're always do you feel like you
love just love working or do you feel
like
you need some more you need structure
you like i mean do you you seem like
someone who just loves to do what they
do
i do i i um
you're right i don't
you know i could step back and agree and
say i don't need to where i don't need
to make a living thank you god and jerry
seinfeld but um
i i enjoy being challenged by something
unfortunately a lot of the things that
come to me as an actor are not terribly
challenging they're they're
knock-off versions of something somebody
has seen me do before and
they in in their heart of hearts they'd
like me to recreate it you know
um and that stuff doesn't interest me
but if somebody says um
like you and i would not want to be an
actor on a mediocre show
but if somebody says hey would you
direct this i go well that's interesting
because can i
as a director elevate this thing in some
way that's an interesting challenge so
by being challenged you open yourself up
to a range of things that you might not
otherwise want to do and you know the
variety of things that i've
sort of forced myself to to do
have always come from well that could be
interesting like the the second broadway
show i did was a musical called the rink
and when i went for the first audition
they went you rollerskate right and i
went ah of course absolutely yeah never
been on them in my life and they said
well in two weeks you come back and
we're gonna do the skating audition
so in two weeks i had to go get an
education on and you know that's the
kind of stuff
that i look back on and i go well that
was sheer madness that was just stupid
to say that i could do something with
proficiency that i had never done
that was also stroke a genius because in
two weeks you go out and you fumble your
way through it and then i got that gig
so that's how i've stumbled onto most of
the stuff i've had to learn to do you
know can you be a do you do stand-up
comedy no well here's an opportunity oh
okay oh give it a shot
really you have you're fearless you're
still fearless after all these years i'm
i'm i i have um
i i i i i am aware i am daunted i am not
undaunted but i also look at and go
you know if i screw it up
nobody dies nobody gets hurt it's okay i
wish i thought all i can be is a little
embarrassing humiliated and if it goes
well it was an experience so i wish i
thought like that i i remember watching
an interview with you and you were doing
an episode
uh
of seinfeld the marine biologist
you were doing it and
they
they didn't have it and so they asked
you at the end
tell this story because to me
it just scared the [ __ ] out of me that
really that they could say can you how
fast can you learn a monologue
um
well really that story is i tell this
this story all the time because it's to
me it's a testament to
to jerry and larry david about not
giving up on something until it's right
so we the ending of that episode
um for those people who may not remember
it my storyline was
jerry had met an old a girl that i had
always wanted to date high school and in
order to impress her on my behalf
told her that i was a marine biologist
and then when he tells me that i go i ca
that's not one of the things i can fake
i don't know how to fake that so i was
trying to pawn myself off as a marine
biologist
and my storyline and that episode ended
when i was walking with her on the beach
and there's suddenly a beached whale and
somebody yells out is there a marine
biologist and you see me
you know like
i'm a dead man walking off into the
ocean to see if i can do anything as
well that was the end of my story
and then the taping in front of the live
audience there was a scene that i wasn't
in with jerry and cramer and maybe lamb
but i think it was just jerry and kramer
which was supposed to be the end of
kramer's storyline
and it was fine it was funny but
it it i guess the guys just weren't
satisfied with the live audience
response they just thought it wasn't
good enough to be the out for the show
so as they always did the writers
circled the wagons and the bands started
to play and he's and then larry came
over and he went
clearly they had gotten an inspiration
in the circle
larry said how long would it take you to
learn a monologue and i said how long a
how long a monologue you said a page and
a half
a couple minutes you know what and he
had written this monologue you know the
sea was angry that day my friends and
cramer had a storyline where he had been
hitting golf balls into the ocean to
practice his drive
but they had never thought of why would
there be a beach whale oh there's a golf
ball in the blow hole so when they had
that inspiration
they wrote this monologue for george to
reveal that he went out and pulled the
golf ball out of the blue
there's no time or place to rehearse it
so they put some screens up between us
and the audience we got on into the set
and the camera guys were given their
shots
we did one run through of it just for
ourselves just to make sure we had the
lines and they pulled the screens away
and said to the audience they're going
to try something we'll see if it works
and
what you see when you watch that episode
is the first and only time
we shot that new rewrite and that became
one of the most
it's one of the big highlight laughs of
the entire series that was a laugh when
i eventually pulled the golf ball out of
my pocket to show it to kramer is that a
titleist
is that a titleist
there was a solid minute or more of
laughter which that's a lot of laughing
where you can't go on you can't do the
next line because the audience is
laughing that hard that was huge
i mean but to me
if a director came up and said how fast
can you learn a monologue i'd probably
say a week maybe a week
very very
a monologue i mean what if you said you
couldn't like your mind doesn't work
like that do you think any cast member
could have done that
uh
i know julia could have done it um
i don't know
probably jerry could have done i don't
know about mike but uh because mike's
mike was always more of a physical guy
than the words um
yeah it's just one of those things i
never struggled with i i i did a one-man
play
in los angeles years ago where i played
harry truman i mean it's a play it's a
two-act play
you know i learned it in two weeks two
weeks you probably learned
50 monologues
it was it was 80 pages of a monologue
yeah
80 pages you learn in two weeks
and give a performance on
but no but you know there are there are
some people that that is a real
that's sisyphus you know pushing it i
never had a problem
with
memorizing
dialogue i wish i could apply that to
anything else i read i wish i could do
it with math or history or science or
anything else i studied i'd be a genius
if someone just wrote it down as a play
i'd have it another what a gift that is
it's a photographic memory right you
have a photographic memory for that
just for that
it was it was
still to this day still to this day if
someone gave you
yeah i don't i don't struggle much with
lines so you never worry about lines at
all because that's always like the
biggest thing for me i need time i want
to really get into this i really need
the
you know
you don't you are so lucky that's a
beautiful obviously don't don't uh think
less of yourself i i know all kinds of
wonderful actors that really struggle
for lines it just it's not
that's not how they're wired and some
people are and i don't think it's a
character flaw i just think it's in the
wiring so what about as a kid like were
you a smart kid were you do you remember
to get good grades
i had i had fine grades um
i was not a ma you know it's it's like i
can't remember which side of the brain
is creativity whatever side was
creativity that was okay the other side
was dysfunctional i couldn't do math or
science
once math once they introduced letters
into math i went okay i'm lost i thought
i thought this was all about numbers
what's going on um
and i couldn't hold abstract facts so
like
you know two carbon atoms and an oxygen
atom i just couldn't hold that stuff
right but english history the humanities
all that stuff great bring it on if you
told me a story
i had it but there was no story to
chemistry and math so i was lost i love
the how much adversity you faced i mean
i think you did because i read these two
things and you've talked about them but
the fact that you know you love magic
and you know somebody said uh you can't
really do that uh you could explain the
story right i want you to talk about
that but then the other one was when you
went to boston university you know they
were like uh you know you'll never do
hamlet because you know you're more of a
character guy you're too short you're
two whatever facing that kind of
rejection early on
is could be crippling and you could be
like i'm done i'm out of it i'm not
going to do magic again i'm never going
to do acting again whatever it is but
first start out because you were crazy
about magic growing up
yeah because i was um i have older i
have half siblings that are
14 and 20 years older than me so i
didn't really grow up with them and my
both my parents worked so i was like a
latchkey kid
and i was a shy kid and i um
and so i didn't have a big circle of
friends and
uh i was i was kind of small and always
a little happy so i was an easy target
for the boys and i walked around kind of
fearful
and magic made me feel powerful i was
like ooh i can do something somebody
else can't so that's why i liked it but
i really did love it
and i i got pretty serious about it even
as a little kid i really spent a lot of
time
working on the stuff and i wanted to be
a close-up guy i wanted to do i wanted
to make the magic in my hands
and by the time i was 12 13 years old i
knew enough kids who were into it
i went to a magic
camp basically
and i was trying to work on this but a
prestigious camp right was it yeah it
was
magic camp right um
and the
one of the you know pros looked at my
hands and he said you know you're gonna
you're gonna have a hard time because
you got little hands to this day
i can barely palm a standard playing
card
one little corner will always peek out
or i have to spread my fingers and you
can see it and so it eliminated a lot of
card possibilities for me and once
once you took away and even like coin
tricks it is better to have
a longer finger you can you can just
manipulate easier if you have bigger
hands right um
and he he basically waved me off of
close-up he didn't say don't do magic he
just said
close-up is gonna be hard but that's
what you wanted to do and that broke my
heart so i you know that kind of but it
broke my heart because i didn't in that
moment have anything that i was equally
passionate about and hard on the heels
of that
came my first opportunity to get into
get in with the theater kids and do
theater and that quickly
that passion quickly replaced the magic
one um
the the
the thing the gift that was given to me
in college by a professor named jim
sproul no longer was
i thought i was gonna be a dramatic
actor i thought i was gonna you know i
was really interested in doing the great
dramatic roles the shakespearean roles
whatever
um
and i didn't see myself as particularly
amusing or funny you know clearly i was
everybody else could see it i couldn't
see it right the mirror the mirror and i
were not communicating um so the sun the
second semester of my sophomore year
this guy pulls me into his office
and i'm you know i'm 20 pounds
overweight i'm already starting to lose
my hair
and he says look i know you your heart
and soul is hamlet and i think you'd
actually be a terrific hamlet but no one
is going to cast you to play hamlet you
should get good at falstaff and he was
basically saying if you want to have a
commercially successful career
you've got to start
doing more get more comedy go do think
about economy and
um
it kind of spun my head around because i
hadn't really thought about it and then
i
created for myself a a syllabus of well
study these people why are they funny
how are they funny what are they doing
what did you study who did you study oh
everybody i went i went and i literally
i i think i wrote it down on a yellow
legal pad about people i had to watch
and listen to
so i i already had the comedy albums i
had carlin and cosby and new heart you
know you name it whoever was putting out
albums um
and then i went back to things and
people that made me laugh why was jerry
lewis funny why was jackie gleason funny
why was lucille ball funny why was joan
rivers funny um
and just you know really why were the
old silent comics funny what what
physically were they doing that made
something that could have been mundane
suddenly spectacularly clever uh and
just tried to you know go oh they have
kind of a sound that they oh they do a
they don't see the thing and then they
see the thing oh they they let the they
use obstacles to get them from keeping
this so it was like this
little tricks here and there uh you know
the one that we used
all the time on seinfeld and it was a
huge once i went
that's a good one it covered a multitude
of sins there was a
if you remember the old honeymooner show
whenever jackie gleason would get angry
at alice because alice was right about
something he'd go
you know it was just this yes
i started using that as george
jerry would say something snide to me
and i'd go
it would get a big lab and i go jackie
gleason okay so and george to me when i
when i auditioned for the show i was
doing woody allen i was doing a blatant
woody allen imitation
and that's what got my foot in the door
and then it slowly morphed into larry
david but um you know my my
sensibility about humor is all stolen
it's just i think we have to steal we
all do i think there's a little jim
carrey in me a little chris farley in me
a little dudley moore maybe in me i
don't know there's like things that i
just i watched arthur probably a million
times
there's one on my face he's taking the
knife out of the cheese
you think he likes cheese let's see
let's see if you have it ready arthur
give me your hand well that would leave
you with one i'll take my hand take my
hand
my favorite line in arthur i think is
when she says
when i was six years old um my mother
died
and he goes go god damn it don't they
know what that does to children
and when i was 11 my father left me he's
like oh so you had six relatively good
years
that's just a dream of it so after this
so you it sounds like to me like you got
inspired when this teacher at boston
university said this and you're like you
started doing all the research you
started doing all this and the next
thing you know
i mean you're jumping in you're doing
broadway not that i mean how long after
well i had a little leg up going in
because i i fell into a children's
theater company that somehow managed to
get itself on tv for one episode of a
thing when i was
14 ish
and it got seen by a management company
so i had i had
reps when i was a young teenager and i
had already started doing commercials by
the time i went to college so i had like
you know a little a little bit of a of a
you might be okay um before i went uh
but i was auditioning for stuff all
through college and then um
yeah i got a film uh after my the the
summer after my junior year the film ran
late i couldn't get back so i took one
semester off
and in that semester my broadway debut
happened and you know things started to
really jump um
but it was
you know
i
i be it's not that i didn't have a sense
of humor it's not that i had never done
like i did the odd couple in high school
i i knew
how to do that stuff but again
um
when i went to college for acting it was
like a revelation to me that you could
that there were skills and craft to
acting because what i had been doing all
along was going who would be good in
this part oh i'll just imitate them so
when i did the odd couple i did walter
matthau i mean i was just imitating
walter
uh can you do a good walter matthau
i could at the time
feel it
you took it all wrong [ __ ]
i told you a million times not to leave
little notes on my pillow you know it's
uh yeah
so it was doable um
so i you know i had i had felt around on
it i had a sense of humor my parents
were were
funny
you know funny for non-professional
people that
could tell a good story and so
i had some raw material to work with i
had some instincts i just never
valued them and i then i began to to go
well you know being funny could be
valuable that's not a bad thing what was
the first big show the one the big show
the big broadway show that broke for me
uh in fact it's so funny because when i
finish with you today i have to go on
seth rudensky's podcast we're having a
reunion
really 40 years it was stephen sondheim
and and george firth wrote uh a musical
version
uh of a play by kaufman and heart called
narrowly we roll along
it was directed by hal prince and i was
20 years old when i got that gig and you
just think well i'm working with christ
and moses this is going to be
it's going to change my career changed
my life and
merrily is a now historic
qualified flop our production was
certainly a flop by any
measure but the show because
i think mostly because of sondheim's
genius score
the show has been done over and over and
over and over and ben platt and beanie
feldstein are doing a movie version of
it that they're going to take 20 years
to shoot because it's a show
that follows these main characters from
the time they're in their late 40s to
the time they're in their early 20s and
it goes backwards and so
the cast of this movie is they're doing
it with richard linklater who's known
for their 20-year project right they're
filming it now and they film a little
bit every year and it'll be done
18 years from now and hopefully they
won't realize what we already know which
is it doesn't really work but
let them learn that for themselves
they'll learn
that's do you prefer
doing stage because i mean it seems to
me like broadway isn't it like eight to
nine shows a week
only eights hopefully yeah isn't that
grueling isn't that a grueling schedule
it is grueling um
and it's hard to understand without
doing it why it would be so grueling
because it looks from the outside like
you're only working six days a week you
do have one day off and you're doing
eight shows in that in those six days
but you know the longest show on
broadway is three hours so on your worst
day you're working three hours you get
an hour and a half off you work another
three hours you go home and it seems
like
that should be doable
it is
you must live a monastic life you cannot
do anything else the demands of
exploding on a stage
that many times a week
cost you physically costs you vocally
you you can't go to a restaurant and
talk over the noise you can't
if you if you enjoy a drink or two you
really can't drink
you
have to keep your body in shape you have
to get your rest you have to kind of
conserve what you've got in order to do
the job and
theater actors are
committed to the job you know they know
they have to get it it has to be there
you can't do another take you can't yeah
i'll get it tomorrow
so
there's a discipline to being a stage
actor that
and a joy that accompanies being that
that's either in your dna or it's not in
your dna i know glorious actors that i i
i wish i had a fifth of their talent
they will not get on stage they just
won't do it right um so it's it's
either have you done a stage yeah i did
a ton of plays in college and then after
i did off off broadway like new jersey
broadway yeah
but i i've done a lot of probably about
20 25 plays and
if given the opportunity would you do a
broadway run
uh i think i think i would if it was the
right part of it was the right
show yeah i think i would i'd
it'd be scary as [ __ ] but did you ever
were your nerves up when you did those
things or were you just excited
there was one play and it was a weird
period of time
i was doing that neil simon thing i
worked on neil simon for and that was my
third broadway show so i had had a
very happy career going
for
you know a solid eight nine ten years
and suddenly in the middle of that play
there was a period where uh the set was
a two-story set and that second story
was a little
dicey and i have a small fear of heights
anyway so i was always a little
a little intimidated working on that
second sword but there was a
period in the play where my character
goes to sleep
i takes a nap in full view of the
audience for about 10 minutes while
another scene plays out and then i have
to wake up and end the first act
and one night a couple of weeks into the
run
as i was lying on that bed i had an
anxiety attack which i had never had in
my life
and i was i was panicking i mean i felt
like my heart was racing i couldn't
breathe and i thought how am i gonna
finish this i can't
got through it and you know it was came
back the next night it was like oh my
god it's here again it's happening again
it became chronic and i
got really scared i thought i can't keep
doing this and i
i talked to a couple therapists about it
trying to see if there was something i
could do medicinally or you know
and nothing worked i finally confided in
my acting teacher it was a dear friend
of mine
and i said you know i'm embarrassed to
even share this with you but i'm having
this crippling anxiety every night in
the show how old are you here
27 27. and i said i you know i feel like
i'm going to ruin the show i'm going to
defend it
and i'm waiting for this very
sympathetic response from him and he
comes back at me and he goes you know
you're a [ __ ] eagle maniac
what because you're making it all about
you you're going to destroy the play
you're going to do the thing you're
going to do that you're going to do that
it's not about you nobody's there for
you they're there for the story tell
them the [ __ ] story
and i went that is brutal but i went to
the theater that night
no anxiety the next night no anxiety it
was gone are you serious just like
that's he he must have gotten into
some odd spiral that i had done that was
just manifesting itself and he just got
me out of me
by saying that and i and believe me i i
studied with larry moss and i had
studied with larry moss for four or five
years up to that point and i stayed with
him another 10 after that point so
he was he was my guy but yeah that was
that was crippling and there's always
the
the good nerves the the you know i i'm
excited about this i want to do if
there's if you're not feeling anything
like that it's time to hand the part
over to somebody else yeah there should
be a little bit of oh
all right let's go i'm excited about
this let's play and if if that's not
happening
so what happened later in life you
started if you got anxiety and then you
go to your wife and she goes oh shut the
f you have a family
this family it's all it's all about you
you eating a maniac
exactly
yeah it opened a very bad door i'm not
allowed to have a bad day
inside of you is brought to you by monk
pack healthy snacks have a bad
reputation ryan and let's be honest most
don't taste very good they don't fill
you up they certainly don't satisfy your
cravings this episode is sponsored by
monk pack who makes snacks that taste
like our favorite sugary treats but with
one gram of sugar or less
monk pack keto nut and seed bars contain
1 gram of sugar or less 2 to 3 grams of
net carbs and they're only 150 calories
and they're great
for anyone following a keto lifestyle
and the perfect snack for anyone who is
trying to eat better or cut back on
sugar and carbs without sacrificing
taste i don't know about you but i'm
always grabbing a a candy bar with too
much sugar and crap in it because i'm
hungry and i need something right then
but if you had the monk pack right there
with you you're eating better you're
just eating better you're doing the
right thing and so have a lot of these
around your house like i do so you can
just scoop them up and you're on the run
you're uh you're eating healthier monk
pack keto nut and seed bars have a
perfect balance of sweet and salty a
crunch from whole nuts and seeds but
still manage to be soft and chewy and
they come in delicious flavors ryan like
sea salt dark chocolate caramel sea salt
and peanut butter dark chocolate which
is my
favorite they're perfect for a quick
snack to satisfy your sweet tooth
without guilt enjoy monk pack keto nut
and seed bars as a quick breakfast while
running errands or after a workout in
addition to being keto friendly the bars
are also gluten-free plant-based and
non-gmo no soy trans fat sugar alcohols
or artificial colors yeah i'm obsessed
with these things and i probably eat
more of them than i should but it's
better than eating the stuff that i'm
eating these are really healthy and uh i
enjoy them try it for yourself and
you'll see and we have a special deal
for our listeners look at this 20 off
your first purchase of any monk pack
product by visiting monkpack.com
and entering our code iou at checkout
monk m-u-n-k monkpack.com and entering
the iou at checkout and monkpack is so
confident in their product it's back
with a hundred percent satisfaction
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll exchange the product
or refund your money whichever you
prefer to get started just go to
monkpack.com again that's m u n
k p a c k dot com and select any product
then enter the code iou at checkout save
20 off your purchase
monk pack delicious nutritious food you
can count on we thank them for
sponsoring our podcast inside of you is
brought to you by geico guys i've talked
to you million times about this listen
i don't go to the grocery store i have
food delivered because i'm lazy or how
about i just like comfort how about i
got a lot going on
so there's geico and geico does the same
thing in a lot of ways they're not going
to get your groceries but here's what
they will do they have bundling policies
right
so they pay your homeowners renters
insurance along with your auto policy
one fell swoop it's that easy it's geico
easy i don't know why everybody doesn't
do this because it's really simple
whether you own your home you rent your
home
uh geico is just gonna make your life a
lot easier um get a quote go to
geico.com
see how much you could save it's geico
easy visit geico.com today that's
geico.com
how did you know you said you had a
really tough audition process during
when you did pretty woman
it wasn't tough it just i had one uh
audition
meeting with gary marshall
and uh he he
he said it's good you could do it it's
good it's good do you
which is good feedback but great
there was no way he wanted me for this
part
he
i was not what he had in his head and he
thought i was too young
uh too baby-faced and uh too small
[Music]
he knew that there was this physical
confrontation with richard gere's role
and uh i think the line that the casting
after tommy
gary
felt like it would look like richard was
beating up a dwarf and since uh
disney was disney's producing this film
and you know they're protective of
dwarfs so
gary i was a non-starter for gary
and without naming the actor he wanted
because that wouldn't be fair but he
knew who he wanted and they couldn't
make a deal with that actor the guy just
wouldn't do it for the money he wasn't
interested
and now the movie was shooting and that
role has to start and they don't have
anybody
and the casting director a woman named
diane crittenden
loved me for this role she just
she kept bringing me up and gary would
get
angry and angrier to the point where he
said if you if you say his name again
i'm gonna fire you
you know
and i think it was like
days before this character had to start
and she
she
somehow got richard gere to agree
to have me go to his office and she was
she brought a video camera
and our height difference you know was
not it was not nothing
so she they put phone books on the floor
and i stood on the phone books to sort
of approximate richard's height a little
more and we played one scene
that she shot and then richard
took that tape to gary threw it on his
destiny this is the guy
and it was under those circumstances
that i
walked into pretty woman
with a director that was not crazy to
have me there but then at the end of our
first day
he he went i was wrong
it's the best we could have so he
he did a complete 180. so richard gere
stuck up for you and fought for you he
did
he did richard
i i mean because of diane crittenden and
richard gere
that movie happened for me without
both of them it would not have happened
and how did you how long did you have to
prepare for that role uh day
i mean
we made that we made that tape on a
wednesday or thursday
and i had to
i think i started shooting on monday or
tuesday
and how pumped were you you're doing a
movie with richard gere was this like
this is the one of the biggest things
you you're doing right now yeah of
course first of all it's a movie i mean
it's like a real i had done a movie but
it was nothing this was this was a movie
and
i think i would have been on cloud nine
except a it was happening so fast and b
i was really i knew
this director doesn't he's not behind me
he's not happy i'm here
and pretty woman was a movie richard
when i got in the makeup trailer on the
first day richard had been shooting for
a couple weeks
and he said uh
get ready because i don't know what
movie we're making here
i i said what do you mean
he said you'll see you'll see
so i mean it's a famous story now but
pretty woman them on paper was
was a much more serious film uh they
didn't end up together at the end the
the depiction of life as a street
prostitute was a little more
realistic it didn't have a lot of its
charms
and gary was
in some ways manufacturing this movie
out of his head so you'd get on the set
thinking you were going to do one thing
you'd wind up doing something completely
different so my
first day i walk onto the set and it's a
short scene
about the business machinations between
our two characters
and
you know i had a couple of things i said
well my character must be very
differential to this rich powerful boss
he's going to be
i had some ideas not many but
and richard had on a very fancy pair of
shoes that day they were just gorgeous
but they were like striking for a men's
shoe it was a very striking shoe
and gary noticed it and so when we came
over to rehearse we started running the
dialogue and gary went wait wait
when richard comes in talk about his
shoes
oh oh all right okay
so
i started
busting richard's chops about hey pretty
fancy look at you tinkerbell where are
you you know so we're playing and gary's
laughing
he go let's shoot it
so we we shoot maybe one line from the
script and a bunch of girl gobbledygook
about shoes and gary goes
cut good let's move on
and i go well wait a minute what about
the the other lines and he goes shoes
are good
and i look at richard and richard goes
that's what i'm talking about oh my god
we when we wrapped pretty woman we we
all had a great time but we thought this
will never see the light of day it's
there's no really there's no story
there's nothing here
and gary had it all we just couldn't see
the forest for the trees
now did they make you wear apple boxes
since in the audition you they made you
taller for the thing did you there were
times when a man maker was called for it
is that what it's called a man maker you
know the the little
inch and a half box it's not really an
apple box it's a quarter apple
a pancake
but uh in my case they always called it
a man maker it's a small
normal man's stature yes many many times
now because a pretty woman that's how
the whole
george costanza came out right that's
how you get so that is part of the
mythology that i've been told so somehow
gary marshall
they were looking for george gary
marshall
married to penny martin
brother penny marshall penny marshall
ex-wife of rob reiner rob reiner head of
castle rock
he says oh i heard this guy i saw a clip
from the movie he might be good you
should put him on tape that's what i've
heard is that somehow it played him and
that's how it kind of started so how did
you get this i mean i know you've
probably told the story a million times
but to get this audition because i want
to hear about the kind of the neil the
uh the uh what's his name woody allen
kind of thing and you put the glasses on
yeah
so
again i lived in new york at the time
all the all the casting on seinfeld was
being done in la they had seen a
gazillion people i guess for george some
very famous who i think had been offered
the role and either turned it down or
they got next do you know any of them or
you don't say yeah i know chris rock
danny devito
the guy one of the guys they really
liked for it and he i think he said no
was paul shaffer
wow
yeah so i mean they were kind of a
little all over the map and uh somebody
said you know we should put some doctors
on
we should get some new york actors into
the mix
so that meant calling a new york casting
director and just saying look we'll send
you a couple of pages we're looking for
a sidekick you know a funny sidekick
best friend to jerry seinfeld
about this age you know
no real description just sort of a
your your standard
young youngish character actor and you
were like who the hell is jerry seinfeld
at this point you probably didn't really
know that i was a fan of jerry seinfeld
you weren't performing many times you
know i i didn't know who the hell larry
david was oh i i knew yours
so i was one of the ones
maybe through this gary marshall
connection and they called and said put
him on tape and all i had was four pages
from the pilot script with no contacts
and nobody asked about it because the
casting director didn't know the project
she was just
being paid to put some people outside so
you quickly memorize them of course
memorizing no problem uh
but i went what do i do with what is
this thing so it to me it read like the
dialogue in a woody allen show
and i went
all right let's go with that so i i
didn't wear glasses at the time i went
out and got you know got
some frames
and
i i not only did in new york a thick new
york accent
i literally was doing woody allen you
know
the gestures in the in the
that voice that voice
yeah
jerry it's it's ridiculous you know i'm
doing woody allen this blatantly nobody
would mistake it maybe not a good woody
allen but definitely a guy trying to do
what he held wow
and i finished the tape and i went
i never i'll never say that again but
you know
and a couple days later got a call i
think from larry um
said love everything you're doing you
know coming out we want to have you meet
jerry you'll read for the network and i
flew out and they said don't change a
thing except
not don't do the woody allen voice do
new york do the glasses do all that but
just don't do the woody allen voice
and i show up to read for the network
and there's one other person reading
that day now i don't know jerry seinfeld
but i do know one thing and that is one
of his best friends in the world at
least at the time was the comedian larry
miller who i had been a pretty woman
with
and that's the other guy reading that
day and i go well
this is the writings on the wall of
course he's going to use his buddy he
doesn't know me so
so i went in to do the ring and i was
loose
i was loosey-goosey and i just had a
great time going i'm not going to get
this so just have fun
and i guess
we you know we just clicked i i left the
audition
got on a plane that night came back to
new york and by the time i landed they
went you got it so
and you didn't know i mean obviously you
didn't have any idea if this was going
to be a success you shoot the pilot did
you when you did it were you like did it
feel like sort of like the pretty woman
atmosphere like what the hell are we
doing here what is this
there's a funny there's a funny moment
where you know we were having our wrap
party on the planet and jerry
says to me what do you think you think
we got a shot
and i honestly i wasn't trying to be
funny i went
you know i don't think so
anyway
why you don't think you don't think it's
good i said no no no i i do think it's
good that's part of the problem
i said
you know at the time that we made that
pilot the number one comedy on tv was
alf
[Laughter]
it felt to me like our show was designed
for an audience of men
not women men
maybe 20 to 35 years old who lived in a
city
and better if they were jews that seemed
to be the audience right and i went
outside of that audience no one's and
those people don't watch tv i think it
is funny i don't watch tv so there's not
going to be an audience for this and
they're not going to do well
i was kind of right it tested horribly
horribly really and they did not pick it
up as a pilot they didn't pick it up
but in those days the networks to fill
space would just throw the dead pilots
on they'd find a time slot and kill a
time slot with a dead pilot
and they aired the pilot and a critic i
think it was tv guide
the critic wrote it a love letter
and everybody went
huh everybody not me i mean the people
with nbc right went huh i wonder if we
missed something here and
they decided they would give it another
shot by making it a summer
sort of special a series of specials
and with that meager order of four more
episodes we and and then the addition of
julia who was not in the pilot
um
we made four more and they tested
terribly too but we kept
hanging in there because the people that
did watch were that audience i was
talking about men from 20 to 35 years
old which was a very tough demographic
for advertisers to get
and the fact that they were our audience
there was always somebody willing to pay
the advertising time to air the show so
that's that's why we hung in there as
long as we didn't
how long did it take to really
feel like you guys
were
together in this like you just
meshed you
you felt like something was because in
the pilot usually the pilot you're still
figuring it out you're looking for out
for your own ass you don't really know
that let him do him let her do her i'll
do me
when did it finally i mean did you feel
like there was any magic or any kind of
connection or did it take a while how
long yeah no so from the get what was
interesting is because you rehearse like
a play you know you rehearse for several
days yeah
i find on single camera shows if you're
not in the scene either you don't you
have no reason to be at the studio or
if you're there and you're waiting for
your scene you're in your dressing room
you're you're hanging you're not hanging
out on the set right we hung out on the
set
nobody ever left the stage and we'd
watch scenes we weren't in and go hey
you know maybe
you know it might be funny if you you
know we were kind of helping each other
and i would say so we did a pilot and
then we did four
four more pilots um yeah four episodes
and then they decided we would be a
mid-season show so we came back to do
13.
and somewhere very early in that 13
i noticed that we were all like
help we instead of fighting for a bit
for yourself
i remember saying this line that i have
would be so much funnier on julia
i mean it would just be so unexpected
it's it's it was just a dig at jerry
and i i said it would just be more
unexpected if it came out of her mouth
and so we tried it and it worked so much
better and that became sort of the thing
of
we weren't
precious about it has to be me it has to
be me it was
the only time i ever made a stink and
larry david will tell you that
it was notorious
is somewhere i think in the four
episodes it might have been the 13th
they did an episode that i was not in i
wasn't in it in kramer wasn't it it was
about
jerry and elaine going to florida to
visit his family i remember that one
and
um i came back the following week and we
got to the table reading we did the
table read and then i
i said to larry and jerry can i
talk to you guys for a minute now
remember i was just visiting la i this
show was not a hit so every time we were
in i
had left my home sometimes with my wife
sometimes not you know because we
weren't making big money so i couldn't
always afford to just have her with me
and the show was by no
means
performing in any way that looked like
the success it would become so i said to
them look guys um
i'm happy to be here i'm thrilled to be
here
if you need me but if you don't need me
to be in this show
i don't want to be in the show i can go
back and do the career i had i was
perfectly happy i'm happy here but i
said to larry if you write me out again
do it permanently
and he he went
through the head he just went it's not
possible
you can't it's four people i can't you
know he was like
apoplectic and i went i hear you i get
it i don't want to be that guy but
honestly i don't need to be here unless
i need to unless i'm needed here
and i look back at it now and go jesus
christ what were you doing
but at the time it felt like i was
making a sacrifice in my life to do this
show that wasn't performing for anybody
yet and i was very happy to go back and
go back to broadway and stuff that i
knew i could reliably get
and so i was i was a
cavalier
wow you just said what you wanted to say
and didn't give a [ __ ] but he wasn't
necessarily mad at you though was he
he wasn't
mad
well i don't i don't think so i mean you
know we've talked about it in interviews
where he went you little [ __ ]
whatever you know yeah i know but you
know but i did feel that way because i i
i i felt like it was very possible
when i did the pilot there was no elaine
there was no other best friend there was
the annoying neighbor
and me and that was the show and the
star
now they have this girl come in
and she's not his girlfriend
she's his ex-girlfriend so she's his
female friend and i went well now you
got two best friends
so you give it do you write for the girl
do you write for the guy the girl's
going to be more interesting my part's
going to go
not not line wise but they just won't
there was no there was no character yet
there wasn't you know you didn't know
why you needed george or why you needed
elaine or whose story would tell what so
i just thought well i'm one of us is
going to be superfluous and now it looks
like it's going to be me because i'm not
in this episode
yeah so i don't you know i don't want to
be the the character they don't need i
just don't want to be that guy right so
that's that's why i said that but
who broke the most on the set the one
that just couldn't keep their [ __ ]
together always laughing and who is your
favorite
who and who's the one who made you crack
up the most
oh well jerry would always i mean you
can watch the episodes and see jerry on
the verge of breaking all the time jerry
jerry was the easiest to pray
but when julia would go when julia broke
she took everybody with her when she
started laughing it was impossible to
not
i could i could stay in character with
jerry i everybody lost it with julian
the one who killed me more often than
not was jerry stella
really
there was just
well first of all i i i'm madly in love
with him i just one of the joys in my
life was was sharing time with him but
um
there was something about
about jerry stiller is so not frank a
stanza they are just like totally
different people and where jerry had to
go to dig that character up and he had
this is the secret of frank stanza
jerry hadlin issues he really thought he
couldn't remember his lines he could
but he was really concerned about it and
the way they would come to him in
performance was in like three words at a
time
and he would get so frightened and
frustrated by it that it created
the rhythms of the frankenstein
character
and they were just so odd and crazy and
had nothing to do with the reality of
the situation so what it what it
inferred
was this tortured backstory of this poor
man who has to deal with these people it
was just
funny and he would have malopropisms
because he'd remember the lines just the
wrong way and
he also had that great hang dog face
that when it would get close you you
just had to hold on and go all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna try and get through this
so um
he could break he and his fellow played
my mom yeah they could they could break
them pretty easily but um they weren't
trying to but they could i i had a lot
of bloopers with them does your uh
family like seinfeld do your kids watch
seinfeld have they seen it do they care
was your wife always like this is a
great show i love it my wife was very
much a part of the reason i was
successful at it because while dana is
not an actress she doesn't do that she
did study to be an actress and she
studied with larry moss it was my
daughter in fact she introduced me to
larry boss
so dana
the way i come at stuff is is a way that
dana understands and
she came to the first
we did 180 episodes i think dana was at
100 tables wow and
you know i would do the first take of a
scene
and larry would come over and give me a
note or jerry would and then i'd go over
dana and she'd say something and i'd go
right right
and then incorporate it so she was very
much
in my ear
and on my shoulder in the creation of
that character
um
and she was invested in the show my kids
no i i think uh i mean the story i've
told before is um when my older son gabe
was about 12
um
that's when his peers
were becoming aware of the show and he
would hear you know hey your father's
george
and he'd never watched it right you know
he was he he knew what it was because it
was where daddy went to work but he
could care less
and uh he finally said what is this
what is it what is the show
so i had videos of them at the time and
they said well here's a couple of funny
episodes gonna take a look this is what
it is so he goes in the tv room and he
watches two or three episodes
and he came out and i'm you know i'm
waiting for him to go hey that's good
you're funny you know i go what do you
think and he goes
you're kind of an [ __ ]
and that was his assessment of the whole
thing
it's not something my boys were
my i think both of my sons while
um appropriately proud of their father
um
have a healthy disinterest in most of
what i do
and because they're both
my my older son gabe uh is absolutely an
actor and a writer and
very funny guy
um
who would love to have a career the way
we do and lives under the shadow of what
my dad
was this and my dad has this level of
success and that never helps
the son or the daughter of
um and my younger son who does uh voice
acting so he doesn't aspire to
everything i do but you know he's
peripherally in the business through
that uh era but they really are
unimpressed with showbiz and me and
uh that's probably healthy isn't it
i i think it's i think it's healthy yeah
i do
you know
i love this story how jerry seinfeld
used to have you guys come in his
dressing room
every every christmas like at the
halfway point of the season and he used
to say
another
like should we do another season
right and you guys all would be like
yeah yeah this is you know you know of
course let's do it yeah and
i just just briefly just you could talk
i just want you to talk about that the
final season where you both felt you you
all felt like this is it
yeah um i you know my my memory is we
probably came into that season
going
[Music]
feels like we're getting there and it
wasn't that i
larry david left after the seventh
season and we did two more seasons after
that
for me personally
the loss of larry was a big loss because
larry was
george and larry had an understanding of
that character
in the scripts that nobody else could
have
and so for me
while there were good stories and good
writing
the the essence of the character was a
little diminished because he wasn't
there to help
fill that void
um
but we got to the halfway point of the
uh of the final what became the final
season and we got into the room and
jeremy went what do you think and for
the first time he wasn't sort of leading
the witness he wasn't going
but yeah we got another one he was like
seriously what do you guys think
and we all we all
[Music]
voiced
the yeah it's probably
it's probably not a bad idea to let it
go and
i know for me personally
what it was about
i felt like the the
the show could continue to be funny
because the writers were funny and we
somehow always were able to find the
funny every week
but i felt like we couldn't surprise the
audience anymore that the characters in
their eccentricities were in some ways
predictable give them a situation and
you kind of know
how they're going to roll on it
and to me
if there is no good indicator of when a
show is ready to kind of wind down
that could be one that serves pretty
well when you become
somewhat knowable and predictable
that that could be a good indication and
you know your the
the spiritual leader of our show was
jerry
who has a professional comic has to know
when to get off the stage
another three jokes
are gonna kill
the high that i've just achieved
and
or you know um
comparatively i i i haven't landed the
big one yet to go off on so he had a
sense of that too and i i think that's
why he was leading the witness in that
meeting going don't you kind of think
we're kind of and i also feel like
in retrospect
he had no life for nine years
if he would i mean we all had a cushy
life we went and did other things our
work week was four days a week you know
some of those days were six hour days
right the cushioniest job in the world
he was either in the writers room the
editing room the casting room
where we had four months down he had
maybe four weeks down before they had to
start coming up with stories for the
next season so i think after nine years
and everything he had not done in order
to do the show
and the amount of success in every way
that it had brought him i think he was
kind of like
i don't want to die here you know i'd
like to get some of my life back
so i i think his attitude led us to it
did you uh i don't think it was wrong
did you guys uh did you ever see any of
them cry when it ended did everybody cry
or was it kind of like all right great
let's go yeah we had a moment so
um
so on a on a
audience show
um there's a warm-up guy who warms up
the audience gets them in the spirit you
know okay you're gonna be part of the
show you're gonna laugh and that's all
that crap
and they introduced the cast you have
like a hey so it's time to meet the cast
and they'd call us out one at a time
we'd come out and wave
so when we were backstage during those
intros we did a thing we did it all nine
years called the circle of power it
meant nothing it was just the four of us
would huddle up
we basically go okay have a good show
all right stupid yeah and then we go out
and be introduced right the circle of
power meant nothing it was nothing just
a moment to say have a good show
on the final episode and we were a very
unsentimental group there was a it's now
famous there was a sign over the writers
room door that said no hugging no
learning you know that's not who we are
um
we got in the circle of power and jerry
said hey can i i want to say something
seriously
okay
and he said
for the rest of our lives
whenever anybody thinks of one of us
they're going to think of all four of us
and there are not three other people on
this planet i would rather have that be
true of
and that and
first of all the sentiment itself was
beautiful but
from a very unsentimental guy
at a very unsentimental time
it just hit us like a brick you know and
and then they go so let's meet the cast
and we
feel like the tears are flowing oh my
god everybody everybody yeah right you
know yeah we were we were pretty
smitten by that um that's great
but you know it's uh i mean you know
you've been there i know it's
it's that moment
this is a this is a family that's not
going to be a family i was on a show
that was called zoe duncan jack and jane
that lasted a year that was supposed to
be the young seinfeld they put us
banners everywhere in this show and we
shot in the old seinfeld studio at cbs
radford and it did not yeah it didn't do
well but you know what could be seinfeld
that's another thing it's like once you
do seinfeld people could always say like
well he's not done anything as big as
cyber because there's nothing as big as
seinfeld
well i mean that's the question i get
all the time is you know
do you get upset going talking about the
show from 30 years ago
you know
um
you know i've had a wonderful career
since seinfeld but nothing near as big
as that show and they go how does that
feel and i go
i didn't expect one
i was going to be a broadway actor if i
was lucky i was going to go from
broadway show to broadway show make a
nice little living and work in the
theater i didn't expect any of this wow
nobody you can't go get this you can't
plan for this i said it was a big deal
that i was on a tv show so a big deal i
was on a tv show that was successful it
was a big deal that i got paid like i
did for a cv show that's successful
here's the biggest deal you want to talk
about it 30 years after it's
not making it
that's like star trek turf i don't know
how to account for that i don't know why
people are still so excited about this
show i truly don't know
i don't i don't begrudge it but i don't
quite understand it why they are still
so excited about this show and it means
so much to them that they want to talk
to me about it and i go you know what
that means it was more than a passing
piece of entertainment for you it meant
something in your life
and if something i did
has that much value in your life i am
honored because
that doesn't usually happen we are
shadows that flicker and then we
disappear and if it has held substance
for you
and you want to talk to me and
ask a question about it or tell me how
much you enjoy it or what it's meant to
you i am
blown away and honored to hear that so
you know awesome you just gotta
i hear you i mean on a smaller scale
when people you know people still want
to talk about some of i'm like you know
absolutely the best thing i did is the
biggest thing i do why not why wouldn't
i want to talk about it uh this is
really quick this is called [ __ ] talking
with jason alexander these are fast
rapid fire questions dave p dave p says
as a huge star trek fan what was it like
to have an actual role as an alien on
voyager
hot [ __ ] damn and working between two
kick-ass actresses jerry ryan and kate
oh my god
awesome cindy h do people recite your
lines back to you and if so any that you
can recall that they want you to say
here's what i get a lot of can't stand
you serenity now master of my domain
shrinkage i was in the pool i get you
know
and the one that's really fun is can't
stand your when you're walking down the
street somebody goes can't stand you and
i go he's referencing a show he actually
likes me
my favorite is uh uh was it called the
dot or the
the red dot the red dot where the
cleaning lady where he asked you he was
like did you know you had a
yes what did anybody say just set it up
what do you say he's coming to my
attention you've been uh
having sexual relations with the
cleaning woman on the desk of your
office and my response was is that wrong
should i not have done that
that is an amazing one that was amazing
uh jerry w favorite director and why
uh joe mantello
i worked with him on the movie version
of love balor compassion
a thousand reasons why but the biggest
one being i learned things as an actor
by being directed by him
if you had to be on the spot right now
to sing something in
10 seconds what would it be
anything anything
uh
my audition song for most of my broadway
career was corner of the sky from pippin
rivers belong where they can ramble
eagles belong where they can fly i gotta
be where my spirit can run free gotta
find my corner of the sky
god just like that no warm-up
by the way when you did barbara
streisand was was it for her birthday at
the hollywood bowl
yeah that you sang from sweeney todd
in front of the whole hollywood bowl for
her but that i mean that sounds like i
wish i was there no i didn't swing
between we had angela lansbury
little from sweeney todd that day didn't
you say no i sang for barbara yes it was
very intimidating what did you sing
hell knows i have no memory i also i had
to go to her house in malibu to meet uh
to possibly direct something that she
was producing years ago and she had
heard her back so she couldn't get out
of bed so
she was in her bedroom i was in the
guest house and i did the interview over
her intercom that was i thought you were
gonna be in her bedroom that would have
been the best
no that would have been lovely yes but
no jason this has been an awesome like a
real treat for me i really adore you
a pl what a pleasure seriously
i you know we gotta have lunch together
for some time let me get by your lunch
let me do something you don't have to
buy me [ __ ] but i will be happy to meet
you you know how to find me you have my
email i have it
call me email me we'll get together
we'll talk uh my partner and i are about
to launch a podcast ourselves i want to
talk to you all about this crazy
business because you're a you're a young
kid you know this turf i don't
understand i'm not that old i'm not i'm
not that young
i'm very old actually i'm not that much
younger than you how old are you i'll be
50 next year
what are you doing what are you eating
almost 50 brother abby and skin cream
oh sure little sunlight
god i'm mighty you look fancy
you know i'm i'm hanging in there i'm
hanging in there it's good lighting in
here i think it's better lighting i
think that's what's going on you look
great all right i love you thank you for
allowing me to be inside of you today
this has been a real joy
my pleasure be well talk to you all
right much love
he just was an open book
that was really cool i love that hearing
the stories about his magic how he loves
magic yeah i love hearing how he likes
to sing and he likes to dance and i like
how much adversity he faced and how he
he just uh did what he loved and he
became tremendously successful doing it
and he's just you can tell he's a
grateful guy he's just a grateful good
dude yeah and uh jason uh we're gonna
have lunch one day you gave me your
email big mistake dude
big mistake
uh let's get into uh before we get into
the top tiers who make this show
possible by giving back on patreon uh
another reminder november 20th i have
two shows my band if you haven't seen us
just give us a chance it's virtual
you can watch it from the comfort of
your own home
um 2 p.m and 6 p.m we have two shows on
november 20th go to stageit.com
uh type in sunspin or go to sunspin.com
you can also get merch there but uh grab
some tickets for you and some friends
and enjoy some uh some tender sweet
music i think you'll like it and um
yeah also the inside of you online store
tons of merch
and uh patreon my lovable patrons who
make the show possible i love you guys
thank you all of you seriously i don't
care if you give a dollar or five
dollars or some of you give way more
it makes the podcast really doable and i
don't know what i would do without you
and i know that you guys love the
podcast and i will continue to try to
give you great shows so thank you if you
want to join patreon go to patreon.com
inside of you patreon.com inside you
right now let's give a shout out to all
our top tier patrons ryan great nancy
dee leah
huh what what did you say leah you said
leah
yeah and uh-huh would you say
remember you're close did you say f you
said f i did say f but it's s that's
house
trisha f sarah v little lisa you kiko
jill e brian h mama lauren
g nico p jerry w robert uh b jason
w kristen k amelia o allison l raj c
joshua d emily s cj p samantha m
jennifer n stacy l jen
um
oh oh no
c
s yes
jamal
f janelle
b kimberly e mike d
close eight
what d
mike d what e mikey
l don soprano 99 more ra mira santiago m
sarah v no sarah f chad
uh chad uh w yes leanne p janine r maya
p maddie s belinda and
chris h dave
r
well h dave h yep spider-man chase
sheila g brad d rey
yes
tabitha
t michelle
b k michelle king michael
uh rosenbaum no michael s talia
m betsy
d yes claire
n i think it's clear eye
is clear i yes that's squiggly again
laura l chad l rochelle nathan e marion
meg
ryan meg k janel p trav l dan and big
stevie w kendall
t t is right angel
investor
investor angel m rhiannon
c corey
l corey k super sam coleman
g dev
nixon michelle
hey yes hey hey
liz i jeremy c andy t cody r
sebastian
the crab k
gav
inator yes correct gaffinator and h
david
uh borianis
c david c john
lennon b brandy d you've
four camille s ban
false five bang bano bano the
c correct joey m willie f christina e
adelaide n jeffrey m omar i lena n
design otg eugene and lee or eugene and
leah however you look at it you got both
of them sure chris p nikki g corey ktb
patriola no patricia
patricia i my glasses i need more i need
better glasses patricia i'm sorry
marie
uh and then i think this is marla
marla n
i'm going to say marianne all right and
bradley yes great thank you guys so much
for listening to the podcast i love you
dearly thank you for making me smile
thank you for caring about this podcast
and myself and ryan and jason and bryce
who worked so freaking hard
and i couldn't do it without them and i
couldn't do without you and thank you
for allowing to be inside of each and
every one of you
and uh please continue to listen to the
show follow the show
and from the hollywood hills in
california my name is michael rosenbaum
my name is still ryan tess
give a little wave to the camera up
there mr ryan bye we love you guys hey
thanks so much for listening and uh
we'll talk to you next week
[Music]